je regarde un peu
[Musique]
on est deux les deux la première
lesparre city parce que c'est une
infantilisation de la société avec un
sur consumérisme de métaux rares le
numérique dans les sources ont
totalement entre les mains de
l'industrie chinoise la deuxième chose
aussi
c'est que
[Musique]
deuxième chose
non mais la bureaucratie vraie
démocratie
il faut par l'administration elle a été
créée par napoléon pour fluidifier
garantir le fonctionnement de la
démocratie aujourd'hui la bureaucratie a
muté comme un virus et a compris qu'un
fabricant à la nuisance elle renouvelle
son territoire existentielle c'est à
dire elle produit de la terreur c'est
donc une atteinte au fonctionnement
démocratique
donc l'administration complotent contre
la démocratie
[Musique]
je suis plutôt bottes camarguaises quand
même parce que je suis d'origine
camarguaise je passais mon adolescence
quentin margaret même m botes toute
l'année été hiver vous imaginez avec une
paire de jeans que je gardais tout l'été
sur moi quand je les enlever le jean
tenait debout
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le béton est tellement
décarbonés que l'empreinte
environnementale est inférieure à celle
du mois parce que le bois pour le
produire il faut tellement de machines
la forêt jusque là syrie extra et le
transport faut arrêter de mentir aux
français mais moins la vertu que je vois
au béton c'est quand même que c'est un
matériau de transmission produit dans
une chaîne courte de de production on ne
fabrique pas du béton en chine en suisse
en allemand mais en inde
voyez en turquie c'est fabriqué des
cendrillons toujours de 20 à 30
kilomètres c'était cette chaîne cours de
production est la meilleure garantie de
la valorisation environnementale de la
matière vous tendrons le jour on arrive
à comprendre que le mot durable c'est
l'amortissement de l'empreinte
environnementale sur le temps
[Musique]
pas 10 ans a rejeté sur le chantier de
mon père j'étais chez les gens qui
avaient des thoniers qui tourne et je
voyais ça lé joaillier est maçon qui
arrivent et le marteau à la ceinture
pour moi c'était les cowboys j'étais
émerveillé je circulais sur le chantier
sans aucune protection sans cassin
chaussures
ni vers libres mais ces cas sont
totalement les français n'y a pas des
protections à la chute vient aujourd'hui
donc c'était c'était pour moi duchesneau
merveilleux ce que j'ai noté car même
c'est que ce que j'aime c'est quand même
c'est que tous ces gens avaient
avait un regard sur le réel
qu'ils avaient une fierté le faire un
métier il faisait un vrai métier dix ans
l'année conscience il développé une
vraie mémoire voilà n'étaient pas des
pantins au service
au service d'une technologie
consumériste voilà
[Musique]